انضم الينا من كابل احد العاملين
بالمنظمات الاغاثيه الدوليه بافغانستان
حمزه حكيمي سيد حمزه مرحبا بك معي في نشره
الرابعه من الرياض انت تعمل في احد
المنظمات الاغاثيه الدوليه في كابول هل
اوقفتم
عملياتكم بعد قرار طالبان بحذر عمل النساء
تحياتي لكم الاستاذ المشاهدين الكرام
وعليكم مستشار في احدى المنظمات الاغاثيه
الدوليه في كابول
تاثرنا جدا سلبيا عن هذا القرار
بما ان منظمتنا نحن لم تتوقف الى الان لكن
ستتاثر بشكل كبير كل فعاليات المؤسسه
فعاليات همم هذه المؤثره الاغاثيه في
افغانستان كما ان هناك يعني مؤسسات منظمات
اضافيه قد تعطلت وقد توقفت عن العمل بشكل
كامل لان هذا القرار قرار محدث جدا وقرار
يعني ستثير مشاكل عديده في ايصال الخدمات
لشعب الافغاني كيف تتعب كيف ستتاثر
عملياتكم حمزه نعم نعم
الفعل المستهدفه او المستفيده من خدمات
المواساه الاغاثيه شريحه كبيره منها
النساء والفتيات في قطاع الصحه قطاع
التنميه البشريه قطاع الاغاثه قطاع همم
المواد التنميه التموينيه وغيرها من
القطاعات الاخرى مثلا النساء ذوي الاعاقه
في افغانستان الخزانات التي تقدم لكل هذه
الفئات من النساء والفتيات تقدمها
العاملات في هذه المؤسسات من النساء فاذا
منعنا هذه هؤلاء النساء من العمل في
المؤسسات من سيقدم هذه الخدمات في
افغانستان وفي القرى وفي المناطق النائيه
لكل هذه الفتيات والنساء همم فالعاملات في
هذه المؤسسات من جانب همم من جانب من
هؤلاء الى عاملات همم يعني تعتبر همم يعني
اعملهن في ال- المؤسسات والمنظمات
الاغاثيه المصدر الوحيد لمعظم هذه
العاملات لعائلهم ومن جانب الاخر والخدمات
التي تقدم من قبل هذه المؤسسات
لشريحه النساء في افغانستان ااا ستتوقف
لان الرجال لا يمكنهم ان يقدموا العديد من
هذه الخدمات للنساء في بيئه تقليديه مثل
مثل افغانستان
فالنساء في افغانستان ستتاثرن من عدم
العمل
متعلقه بالنساء ربما العزيزات او النساء
همم
التي يعني يطلبن خدمات ربما لا تقدمها سوى
النساء لهن يعني فهل بحثتم هذه النقطه مع
طالبان او اثارتهم هذه النقطه بعد ابلاغكم
بهذا ال- ال- الخبر خبر تعليق عمل للنساء
في منظمتكم
يبدو الى الان ان يبدو المسؤولين الان غير
مبالين بهذه الامور المسؤولين في الحكومه
الطالبان هم فقد اصدروا القرار وس يعني
غير مبالين الى الان يعني باثارها هذا
القرار على المجتمع الافغاني وعلى الشريحه
المستفيده من شعب الافغاني المعظمهم
للفقراء الذين يستفيدون من هذه الخدم لان
الحكومه بنفسها غير قادره على تقديم على
هذه الخدمات فمثلا في القطاع الصحي همم
يعني نسبه كبيره من الخدمات القطاع الصحي
تقدمها المنظمات الاغاثيه الدوليه في
افغانستان في معظم الولايات همم ومعظم
المناطق والكره همم فاذا منعنا همم
العاملات في هذه المؤسسات من تقديم
الخدمات والمجتمع الافغاني لا تسمح لتقديم
هذه الخدمات من قبل الرجال الصحيه للنساء
فهذا بالطبع سيزيد من الضغط همم داخل
المجتمع على افغاني وهذا الضغط سيشعره
المسؤولين المسؤولون همم بدرجه الاولى في
الحكومه في الحكومه الطالبات لذلك نرى ان
يعني هناك قلق بالغ وقلق شديد في وسط
المسؤولين في المنظمات الاغاثيه الدوليه
وقلق بين العاملين والعاملات في هذه
القطاع ممتاز تتحدث عن قلق تتحدث ايضا عن
ان النساء سيتاثرن ايضا بايقاف عمل هذه
المنظمات ونساله هنا عن البديل لهذه
المنظمات سيد حمزه ما هو البديل اذا غادرت
هذه المنظمات الدوليه الاغاثيه الانسانيه
في افغانستان وهي التي تعاني من اوضاع
اقتصاديات توصف بالصعبه وانسانيه توصف
بالاصعب حتى كذلك
همم بطريقه الحاله المسؤوليه على عاتق
الحكومه على عاتق الجماعه التي تدير
الحكومه الان وتعتبر نفسها بانها الحكومه
تشكل الحكومه في افغانستان لكن بوجود
المؤسسات الاجنبيه والاضافيه الاجنبيه في
افغانستان الحكومه غير قادره على تقديم
هذه الخدمات فبعد المغادره هذه المؤسسات
من افغانستان بكل تاكيد ستتفاقم الازمه
بشكل كبير وسيزيد الضغط على اعتق الحكومه
التي هي اصلا عاجزه عن تقديم الخدمات
للشعب الخدمات في المختلفه في القطاعات
التي تغطيها هذه المنظمات الاغاثيه همم
البديل لابد على الحكومه ان تقدم بديلا
وهي اصلا عاجزه عن تقديم البديل لكن همم
على اي حال الضحيه همم ستكون شعبا
الافغاني الذي يعيش اكثر من
79% من هذا الشعب تحت خط الفقر وهي شعب
وهو شعب محتاج جدا لهذه همم
المساعدات الانسانيه والاضافيه لكن هذا
الشعب
ااا يعني يدفع القيمه وسيكون الضحيه طيب
همم هل لديكم معلومات او تفاصيل عن
المنظمات الاجنبيه التي اعلنت انها ستعلق
عمالها في افغانستان قبل قليل ان نتحدث عن
ثلاث منظمات حتى هذه اللحظه انت مستشار في
احد هذه المنظمات الاغاثه الدوليه يا سيد
حمزه هل لديك معلومات
يعني بعض الاتحادات لهذه المناسبات او كما
يقال امبريلا اورجانيزيشن يعني همم منظمات
يعني اتحادات همم
تنضم تحتها العديد من هذه المنظمات اليوم
كان هناك يعني مجالس عديده بين هذه
المنظمات المختلفه واا سيصدر قرار موحد من
قبل همم المنظمات الاغاثيه الدوليه
والمنظمات الاغاثيه المحليه هناك يعني همم
مجموعه اخرى من المنظمات الاغاثيه الاهليه
الافغانيه داخل افغانستان همم في همم في
اتحاد لهذه المنظمات سيكون هناك قرار موحد
همم من قبل هذه المنظمات ونحن في هذا حاله
من الترقب حتى يكون هناك موقف موحد وحتى
يعني همم وهذا الموقف همم يعني سيكون له
تاثير على همم هذا القرار وسيكون له تاثير
على مستقبل العمل الاغاثي لهذه المنظمات
في افغانستان رزيل الشكر من كابو المستشار
باحدى المنظمات الاغترافيه الدوليه
بافغانستان حمزه حكيمي